Oh where did you come from the future
time travel is read yeah you have no
idea but why did you travel back to at
this moment in time I'm just typing
anyways I just saw the movie looper with
you and yeah movie where they send
people back in time to kill people and
then Bruce Willis the same person you
don't see it why not
because you're gonna hate it but it's
not bad it's actually really awesome but
you're gonna nitpick all the time throw
a lot to do stuff it's interesting that
the movie thinks one guy can be in one
time twice and not you know cause some
sort of space-time continuum if you
write exactly this right that's just one
of the things that you're gonna come
with well at the end like he's trying to
kill this guy before he becomes evil but
you know trying to kill him is what
makes it turn evil in the first place
that's impossible
yeah I know that's my point you're gonna
see you've come back in time to warn me
and stop the way I'm seeing the movie
right right doesn't that create a
paradox in and of itself how you know
like if you are successful and I decide
not to see the movie you can't be here
you have to disappear I think I'd be
willing to disappear if it means I don't
have to listen to your complaining about
this movie forever okay
I won't see it then thank you you did
disappear
it's no paradox don't see any way dude
what the